hello welcome to the section
on multi-class classification
so remember the key ideas here we're
trying to
do classification where the target
variable can take one of
k possible values and
we have raw target values
which are say numbered 1 through
capital k and but we embed those
using the map y is equal to
psi of v and as a result y
can take one of capital k values psi
1 through psi capital k each one of
those is a vector in
rm we get to choose what m is we get to
choose what those psi 1 through psi k's
are and once we've done once we've got a
predictor that produces a y
from an x we have to get back
to a v and the way we do that
is we look at the the y hat that we've
got produced by the projector
and we look over all of the different
size psi 1 through psi k to find the one
that's closest to the y hat
and that's going to tell us which of the
classes
to unembed and give us the resulting
v-hat
and of course the predictor that
produces y-hat from x is constructed via
regularized empirical risk minimization
now at the end of the day what we do is
we validate using the name
and pearson performance metric on the
test data so we've picked our kappas
where kappa j is our distaste
our displeasure in mistaking um bj
and our performance metric is then the
sum over j of kappa j
ej where e j counts the number of times
that
we mistook v j
and of course if all the kappas are one
that's just the
error rate
now we're going to want to construct a
loss function and it's not quite so easy
as it was in the boolean case so in the
boolean case remember how it worked let
me just use this as a little
sketch pad here we
embedded
so this is our m where m is one
so we embedded at plus one and minus 1
and we'll call this psi 1 and side 2
and then we had ideal loss functions
from the name and pearson loss
so if the true y was
y was uh 1
then our ideal loss function
would be this
our ideal loss function would be this
and it would say
that since y was 1 our ideal
y hat should be anything negative
so we want to generalize this idea to
the case where
we've now got multiple psi i's not just
2 and we've embedded them in
our m and m is not just 1.
so the first idea we need is simply to
know when a vector is closer to
one point than another point and that's
so here we have two points
we have point a and point b
and we have here this green line
and this green line is the
perpendicular bisector
of those two points and uh
that comes about mathematically in the
following way
if i ask when is a vector y-hat closer
to a
than it is to b well the distance
um from
y hat to a is just the norm of y hat
minus a
and the distance from y to b is the norm
of y hat minus b
and so we can ask ourselves the question
when is one closer than less than the
other
that's this inequality right here
now we square both sides those are both
two norms what happens
is we get an expression which looks like
y hat minus a
norm squared is less than or equal to
the norm of y hat minus b
squared and if we expand those squares
well then we get that the
y hat transpose y hat
minus 2 a transpose y hat
plus a transpose a is less than or equal
to y
hat transpose y hat minus 2
b transpose y hat plus b
transpose b
and the nice thing about this is that
those
quadratic terms in y hat go away
and this inequality reduces
to this inequality it is this inequality
2b minus a transpose y hat minus the
number b
squared plus the number of a squared is
less than zero
and in particular the thing to notice
here is that this only depends on
y hat in this nice
simple way here right it's a vector
transpose times y hat
and so this is equal to zero
along this green line it's
less than zero when
y hat is on the
a side and it's greater than zero
when y hat's on the b side of the green
line
and the decision boundary explicitly
just replacing that inequality with an
equality is right here that's a
hyperplane
that's an equation of the form c
transpose y is equal to d
where c is a vector in r m and d
is a scalar
in here in particular c is
2 b minus a
and d is the norm
of a squared minus the norm of b
squared
and this hyperplane has to pass through
the midpoint of a and b
and you can check that it does by
substituting
y hat is
a plus b on 2 into
this equation right here and checking
that you get 0.
now we can use this
analysis to construct a notion of signed
distance from the hyper plane h
so the hyper plane h is
here it's this green
hyperplane that's the perpendicular
bisector between
a and b and we're going to say
that we're going to measure the distance
from h
and so i'm going to have some points
on this side
and some points on this side and these
points
we're going to say our distance minus
one
from the hyperplane h
and these points we'll say our distance
one
so instead of labeling them both as
having distance one the ones on one side
will get negative distance and the ones
on the other will get positive distance
and our point y-hat here
has some distance here which is about
minus two from the hyperplane
i might have another point say over here
and that would have a distance uh plus
two or maybe slightly more than two the
way i've drawn it
from the hyperplane and
uh where does this formula come from
well
we have this nice formula here
which is uh
this inequality here which is uh
and it defines for us which side of the
hyperplane
we're on and it has the form of c
transpose
y plus d now
over here we've simply taken that and
taken that the value of the left-hand
side of that inequality and made it
equal to our distance measure
but we've scaled it we've scaled it by
2 the norm of b minus a and as a result
d
has this form
d is equal to u
transpose y plus
v where u here is a unit vector
it's b minus a divided by the norm
of b minus a and because u is a unit
vector
it's measuring
distance uh which is corresponding to
the unit distances that we use
in the plane so in other words
if y hat actually is a distance
d from the hyperplane
then capital d here will be the
appropriate sign
appended on to y-hat
um
so d is zero that's the decision
boundary that's the
uh that's the decision boundary that
decides whether we're on
the a side or the b side of the
hyperplane
and uh if it's negative we're closer
to a than we are to b
um so why do we
want a notion of signed distance
um and the idea goes like this suppose
we have
let me draw a picture uh
so this will be r2 so here m is two
so we've embedded our
categorical variables in the plane
r2 and the embedding points well let's
just pick them
let's put one over here
one over here and one over here
and i will label those
psi psi 2
and psi 3 and those are the points
to which our categorical target
variables
embed now
with those points we're going to
say okay well those are our embedded
points we'd like to define a loss
function with those points that's what
we'd like to do
now the idea is of course is that we're
going to have a predictor that produces
for us a y
hat and we would like that predictor
to be inclined to give us a y
hat that's close to psi one when y is
one
and a y hat that's close to psi two when
y
is two and a y hat that's close to psi
three
when y is three so let's divide up the
plane
into regions
the voronoi partition of the plane
like that and then this
region right here
this region here is the region
uh which if we have a y hat within that
region
then it's unembedded back to psi one and
therefore back
to the target value corresponding to psi
one
and so what we'd like is we'd like to
have a loss function
which encourages y
hat to lie within that region
when y is equal to psi one
we can imagine such a loss function
here's what it would be
it would be zero if y hat
lies in that region and one elsewhere
it would be one here
and zero
here and such a loss function
would count up for us the rate
at which we mistook y1 for something
else
and so in our loss function if we summed
up that and divided by
n that would give us precisely the rate
which we mistook for y 1 for something
else
and so kappa 1 multiplied by that loss
function
would count up for us the name and
pearson contribution
of the loss for
the target psi one
and then we would do another one we'd
have a loss function
of course we've got a different loss
function for
y1 y2 and y3
and so
if i look if this is y1 this is y2
with this is y3 i would have a loss
function which was
0 here and
here and that would be the loss function
corresponding
to y is equal to 2.
and so we have three different loss
functions functions of y hat
one when y is psi one one when y is side
two
and one is when y is psi three and then
each one is zero
on the region corresponding to its psi
i so how do we construct such a loss
well what we can do
is we can use the signed distance
functions
d i j and what d i j is going to be
it's going to be the distance the sine
distance of y
hat from the boundary between psi i
and psi j let's look back at our example
this is psi one psi 2
and psi 3 now
d 1
2 is less than 0
when we are closer
to psi one than we are to side two
so d one two is less than zero whereas
that
that's everywhere to the left of this
line
where is d13 less than zero
that's everywhere below
that line let me mark my two lines
and so if d12 and d13
are less than zero
well then i'm in the region belonging to
psi one
and similarly i'm in the region
belonging to psi2
that's this region if d
if d
two one is less than zero and d23 is
less than zero
and finally over here i have d3 one
is less than zero and d3
2 is less than zero so in other words i
need
for any given region for any given i
if i want y hat to be in the region
belonging to psi i then i need
d i j to be less than zero for all the
other j's
now that we've got these signed distance
functions we can use them to construct
our ideal
loss functions
here's some examples to be explicit in
the most common cases the most common
cases are of course the boolean
in the boolean case m is one and so i've
just got r here
psi one is minus one
and psi two is one
and then i've got d one two
is less than zero over here
and d two one is less than zero
over here
and so if y is
in the region corresponding to psi 1 so
that means
that y is -1 well
then we need we
would like d12 to be less than zero
and that would be and then we'd have a
loss function
which was zero over here say
enlarge over here and that would be our
ideal loss function
our name and pearson loss function
similarly if y is plus 1 then
we want d21
y is plus 1 and that corresponds to psi
2 and so we want d
2 1 of y hat to be less than 0
and d 2 1 of y hat is minus y hat
and so we want y hat to be greater than
zero
if we look at the one hot case that's
their psi j
this should say e j let me just correct
that psi
j is e j
and if we
compute what d i j is well the distance
between d
i j let's just look at it
this is psi one and this
is psi two in two dimensions if we're
embedding using one hot
this is of course one zero and this is
zero and so the distance between those
two points is simply root 2
and so d i j is y j minus y i
on root 2. where in order to compute
that of course we've used
our definition here
2 b minus a transposed y hat
divided by 2 the norm of b minus a
obviously the 2's cancel
and b minus a transpose times y hat
because gives us y hat i minus y hat j
or y hat j minus y hat i depending on
the sign
so when y is e i we want the max over
all j not equal to i
of d i j to be less than zero and that
means that we want
y
j minus y i to be less than zero
and that's the same as saying that y j
is less than y i
so in other words we would like the
corresponding uh
component of y hat to be
the maximum component of y hat
so let's use these to construct loss
functions explicitly
um what we've got to do well we've got
to give k
different loss functions one
corresponding
to each of the possible values of y
remember loss is a function of y
hat and y and y here can only take k
possible values
which we've denoted as l of y hat comma
psi
i it's how much we dislike predicting
y hat when y is psi i
in other words if to come back to our
example
if
d12 is less than zero and d13 is less
than
zero then we'd like the loss function
corresponding to l of
y hat psi one
to be small enlarge
when y hat doesn't satisfy these two
conditions
that gives us immediately the name and
pearson loss we can consent
a loss function of
zero on the region corresponding
to psi i and kappa i
elsewhere and that means when we take
the average
of that name and person loss we get
kappa i times the frequency with which
y hat is mistaken y hat
gives an answer which is not i when y
truly is i
and this is of course the analog of our
nice
square loss functions that we've seen
before
now the downside is of course that it's
hard to minimize
this these discontinuous loss functions
which have derivative zero almost
everywhere
and so instead we use what's called a
proxy loss a loss that
approximates the
name and person loss but is it more
easily optimized
so we either would like it to be convex
or differentiable
or both
so here's the perhaps the one of the
there there are two
really common loss functions that are
used one is the hinge loss this is the
multi-class hinge loss
it's kappa i times the maximum
of 1 plus d i j of y
hat and we're maximizing it over all j
not equal to i and this is a loss
function which
is zero
if y hat is in the right region with a
margin of at least
one right so it has to be not only
within the right region but it has to be
deep within the right region
and this is a convex but not
differentiable loss
if you use quadratic regularization then
it's multi-class
support vector machine if we
have a boolean embedding then psi 1 is
-1 and psi
2 is 1 then it reduces to the usual
hinge loss that we've seen before
it's 1 plus y hat the positive part
times kappa 1 when y is minus 1
and it's the flip of that
when y is 1.
here is the corresponding surface plots
for it in the case which we've been
discussing so far
this is our um
example we've got three size site one
site two and size three
and you can see you've got a loss
function which
is convex which is
piecewise linear and which is
zero when you're deep within each of the
three
regions so of course we've got three
loss functions here
in the top right graph here we have the
loss function
corresponding to the case when
y is one yeah
y is psi one in the bottom right we have
the case where y
is psi three and in the bottom left we
have the case when y is psi
two now if you look in particular at the
top right
when y is psi one you can see that the
last function is zero
when we are
deep within the region corresponding to
y
one
here's the other most common loss
function the multi-class
logistic loss so this
is the following here this is the
log of the sum of the dijs
so if all of the dijs are
less than zero
then this is going to be well
the sum of e to the e to the negative
numbers
and so it'll be a relatively small
quantity
and it will grow as the dijs grow
it's complex and differentiable it's
called a multi-class
logistic loss and if we use this
as our loss function we're doing
multi-class logistic regression
so here's a plot
of that loss function again we can see
three different loss functions each one
associated with a different
region of the plane corresponding to our
different representatives
and for each one the loss function is
small
on the corresponding region and grows
outside the region
now the log sum x function
is what's at the heart of this loss
function this is an interesting function
because it is convex differentiable
and it's approximately the maximum
function
sometimes people call it the softmax
function but you should be careful about
that because there are other
functions also used in machine learning
as it happens
that are also called the soft max
function
the one of the nice thing about the
locksmith x function is that
we know how far it is from the max
function
it's always greater greater than or
equal to the maximum of the excise
and it's always less than or equal to
the maximum of the excise plus log n
let's look at an example this is
a a three class example this goes back
to 1936 is a very famous data set
which was collected by the statistician
fisher
he took measurements of 150 different
plants all of which were three different
species of iris
so there's 50 from each of the three
different species
and for each of those samples he made
four measurements the simple length the
sepal width
the petal length and the petal width
we can plot them here so this plot this
is simply an arrangement of all
the data so for example in this plot on
the top right
we've plotted sepal lengths on the
vertical axis against petal width on the
horizontal axis
you can see that there are three species
the reds
there's some one of the species
indicated in red one of them in green
and one of them in blue
you can see that telling the mid from
the others is rather straight forward
and turning the green and blue part is a
bit more difficult
so here we've done classification with
using only two of the features
simple length and simple width and those
are plotted
in this figure again we can see green
dots blue dots and red dots and it's
relatively easy to separate the red dots
and this is the using a linear predictor
with one hot embedding multi-class
logistic loss
and we're minimizing the probability of
error so that the kappas are all one
and here there's no training in test set
we simply trained it on all the data
of course if we had more data we would
be using a training and test set and
would also be using regularization
the confusion matrix shows us what we
can see from the figure
that we've got all the red dots
perfectly correct
we haven't mistaken anything for a red
dot
but some of the greens and blues we've
got wrong we've mistaken
12 greens for blues and 13 blues for
greens and
as you can see in the in the figure it's
there's no
clear way to separate the greens from
the blues
now if you do classification with all
four features
of course you can't plot it anymore um
same thing one hot embedding
minimize the properties of error well
then you can do much better
then you can get a confusion matrix
where there's only one
error out of 150 plants one
sorry two errors two misclassifications
we've got one blue classified as green
and one green
classified as blue
so let's summarize when we're doing
multi-class classification
we'd like a loss function that
encourages the correct unembedding
so when y hat is close to psi
i well then we want l of y hat psi
i to be small and we want to be not
small
when y hat is not close to psi i
the most common losses people use are
the multi-class hinge loss
and the multi-class logistic loss and
these two classifiers are called the svm
and the logistic classifiers
and both of these classes are both of
these losses are convex
so we can solve easily the erm or the
rem problems in the case where the
predictor
is a linear predictor